let us now illustrate the linear list
mean square estimation methodology in
the context of an example and we're
going to revisit our familiar example
that we considered earlier in the
context of general least mean squares
estimation let us remind ourselves what
were the assumptions behind this example
there is an unknown random variable that
we wish to estimate and that random
variable happens to be uniform on a
range from 4 to 10 what we get to
observe is a random variable X which is
equal to theta plus or minus something
so X is theta plus a noise term and that
noise term can be anything in the range
from minus 1 to plus 1 furthermore the
distribution of U is this particular
uniform no matter what theta is so theta
and you are independent these modeling
assumptions correspond to this picture
this is the range of X and theta and the
Joint Distribution of X and theta
happens to be a uniform distribution on
this particular shape however we're not
really going to use this picture other
than for illustration purposes you could
take just this as the formulation of the
problem that were interested in so now
to develop the form of the optimal
linear estimator all we need to do is to
determine the various constants that
show up so let's start with expectations
theta is uniform from 4 to 10 therefore
the expected value is the midpoint which
is equal to 7 u has a symmetric
distribution around 0 so it's expected
value is it going to be equal to 0
X is the sum of theta and u therefore
its expected value is the sum of these
two expected values and is equal to 7
let us now look at variances the
variance of a uniform is equal to the
square of the length of the interval on
which the uniform is distributed in this
case it's 6 squared divided always by
coefficient on 12 6 squared is 36 so we
obtain 3 the variance of U is determined
by a similar formula except that now we
have an interval of length 2
so we obtain 2 squared over 12 and this
is 1/3 now let us look at the variance
of X since X is the sum of theta and you
and since the two of them are
independent the variance of X is going
to be the sum of these two variances
which is 10 over 3 now let us try to
calculate the covariance term the
covariance of theta with X is this
expression because X is Theta plus U and
then using linearity properties of
covariances this is the covariance of
theta with itself plus the covariance of
theta with you now theta and you are
independent so this covariance is equal
to 0 the covariance of theta with itself
is just the same as the variance so here
we obtain an answer of 3 and so now we
have all the pieces of information that
we need and we can proceed and write
down the form of the linear estimator
the expected value of theta is 7
then the covariance of theta with X is
three divided by the variance which is
ten over three so this ratio becomes
nine ten and then X minus the expected
value of X gives us this term so this is
the form of the optimal linear estimator
and if you wish to plot it it is a curve
of this kind it is actually interesting
to contrast this solution to the shape
of the optimal estimator the least mean
squares estimator or the conditional
expectation estimator which we had found
earlier and which corresponds to this
particular blue curve so in some sense
the linear estimator is a pretty good
approximation of the optimal nonlinear
one it does the best job that it can do
subject to the constraint that it has to
be a linear function notice also that
this coefficient here is of course
positive this reflects the fact that two
random variables X and theta are
positively correlated this should be
clear from this diagram when x increases
theta tends to also increase and vice
versa it's also reflected in the fact
that the covariance is a positive number
on the other hand because this
coefficient is 9/10 and not equal to one
this red line is somewhat slanted in
comparison with the orientation of the
diagram that we have the calculations
that we went through in this particular
example are pretty generic this is what
you need to do in general you just look
at the random variables involved you
calculate their means you calculate
their variances then you may have to do
some extra work to calculate the
covariance of interest and once you are
done you
again the numerical values that you have
found and you obtained the form of the
linear estimator